welcome to this video playing civil
civil okay let's see I just wanted to do
something a little bit different not the
mainland opening I could have led efore
actually this would have been quite good
I on haha okay maybe I can still play
you for a night yeah of course instantly
I we grab this porn haha yeah it's
probably a good porn grab a min but it's
just funny that they decide on it like
in a split second okay it's opening up
the C file for me don't mind that
and this is definitely quite good
compensation for white
I have like three or four extra
development Tempe I came so how are we
going to do that d five maybe rook see
one yeah I don't know many possible
possible continuations master tech here
is probably not bad he I don't think he
can really cover the sea porn 96 looks
wrong with like t5 and giving me more
tempe I don't know maybe he just
cancelled give up the gift to give up
the pawn
k going to take that
possibly night season c4 to the six
seven sisters could be could be an ATM
I need to be need to be quick i er
otherwise my initiative evaporates yeah
of course plate instantly seem into this
in 95 s what i want i intended to threat
not f7 and on c6 well let's see so i can
take but i can also try to play for for
further attacks like 93 94 or quincy one
quincy wonders rook c8 yeah okay now
let's check let's get some material back
it's probably not bad also considering
that this move is threatening a quick
quincy seven and King d7 I have 93 which
should be really nice this King is
simply not very secure so Knight f3 yeah
and you get in also Queen g5 as a
possible attacking move and 95 again
okay Quincy seven Queen f7 mate and some
quite quite a big threat
yeah I guess that's it huh Queen f7 mate
yeah it was a very difficult resign very
difficult to defend position he was very
greedy I with Queen before basically
playing and playing in a split second
yeah it took him two seconds to decide
to give up all development okay I don't
think it's so bad really but it is
definitely risky yeah yeah here it gets
tricky i mean what i find remarkable is
that you played king diate instantly or
four seconds I mean it's not like I was
I wasn't seeing that the rookie strapped
gym now in this this is what I was
thinking and this is not clear I mean a
45 maybe and now it's it's not so clear
whether we're the night is going goes
here I have I don't know what I have
actually yeah maybe push it back or
something I mean I have 10pm moves like
that with Roxy six it's it's very
unclear okay you went there take sticks
95 and i'm not sure what this is can't
mean I definitely have compensation for
porn but if it is better than that okay
the computer likes a 5 here ok and now
and now white already has an edge yeah I
couldn't care d takes e4 seems to be
okay the computer gives yeah but now he
has to do something else takes on d3 is
still ok m ok check something like that
this it seems to be ending in a draw
with some sort of Perpetual check yeah
that's believable the deep onus is
strong the key point is stronger maybe I
have to force the draw but with this
he's just walking into the mate ok wow
that was so surprisingly quick at the
end ok thanks for watching